on this episode I talk about shifting TV
budgets to video I talk about wine yeah
I still talk about it and I talk about
how do I stay on top of Technology from
San Francisco you keep asking questions
I will continue to answer them everybody
this is gary vay-ner-chuk and you're
watching episode 29 of the askgaryvee
show fun fact about 29 I don't have one
and so here we are you have not seen the
SF office most of you Michael
vaynernation have never seen the SF
office so it's exciting for me to now
tape an episode here in San Francisco a
tremendous crew of peeps here big shout
out to all of you guys I'm thrilled to
be doing this with you guys
also I'm trying a little bit of a new
format today I'm going a little bit
shorter so feedback question today when
you think of the three question format
versus the five question format yes I
did the question they upfront deal with
that then ask what do you think about
recent Omnicom advice to move 25% of ad
budgets to online video so for the small
businesses or the entrepreneur some
becomes a big kind of conglomerate
agency in my vaynermedia world these
days and they do a lot of what's called
working media the dollars you spend for
distribution not to create content
something we do a lot in social channels
but not on TV print radio all that kind
of stuff so you want to set the stage
for that question you know the thing
that scares me with that general kind of
statement is that when people think of
online video they think about spending
five ten percent of the overall budget
let's call it $100,000 on the video
production the quality of the stuff and
95 on the distribution and then what
they spend on the emini up to eat maybe
eighty to ninety it would say eight the
only polite here today in San Francisco
because it's got a little bit more of a
polite vibe within New York of that
eighty percent they pounded in right
hook form what is unlike video mean to
most people let me just explain what it
means it's pre Bulls on YouTube
people tap out and don't actually
consume it it's you go to these pin that
comment a video pops up and takes over
30 seconds of my time which pisses me
off
and so what I'm most worried about when
I hear people allocating and it's part
of a bigger story which is that people
are talking about moving TV budgets into
other places my problem is I actually
like live television commercials more
than I like banner ads on websites and
pre-roll video that's blocking the user
from doing what they want so this isn't
about traditional or digital this is are
you bringing value and when I here move
from television and put it into online
video what I know is going on an actual
practitioner world is people are
spending that money on online video that
is annoying customers and putting in
places where they don't want it versus
putting more percentage of the money on
actually creating great video and then
figuring out a more native way to
distribute it that being said Facebook
dark posts video native to me is a very
attractive option especially if you've
been seeing it the audio doesn't play
but if you're into it you click it and
so that's my overall thought which is
that in theory it's great double moving
traditional dollars here but I see a lot
of people miss playing digital Laura
asked on Fridays we drink wine what's a
good drinking home alone bottle to
yourself wine loora loora loora loora
vega white wine fan and so the place
where I'm really obsessed with these
days is Italian whites non Pinot Grigio
so npg and what I mean by that is look
for things like suave look for Greco - -
faux look for fian oh these other white
varietals from Italy where a lot of
people don't know them they don't
realize their quality and I think
between eight and twenty two dollars you
can get an enormous array a tremendous
high asset quality drink by themselves
but wait I'm drinking it by itself but
now a lot of little cheese still is able
to fold into that so Italian white wines
to me are grossly and stunwin because I
know
you're gonna be with d-roc when you edit
this episode throw up a couple of logos
of labels here actually take over my
whole face show like seven or eight
logos of Italian whites in that 8 to 22
dollar range that people can like
slow-motion this video and they catch
them a mother link it down below
Matthew asked you talk about upcoming
companies and predicting their success
where and how do you find these rising
companies this is why I love this damn
show we are getting into actual tangible
stuff not just the sizzle that I have to
do on stage cuz I don't have an hour and
I got to make you pay attention and then
drill you this is the quality of this
show
here are two tangible things you should
be every day I'm gonna have a third
three things Jason Hirschhorn absinthe
applause because I was gonna say Google
it and then I wanted to say Bing it and
I got caught you know I never get caught
so a little rusty here in San Francisco
Google Jason Hirschhorn media rep I
think is what it is he's got a
newsletter tremendous way to stay on top
of it Tech mean
TCH Emmy Emmy recode these are two blogs
that I think will take memes an
aggregator of all the news I go there
every morning to see what's bubbled up
recode I just like in general and
consume TechCrunch that's loose in the
salad but tech mean aggravates
everything so I go to tech Emmy and the
every morning I read everything that
helps me see things and then my littlest
funnest hack I go into the iTunes App
Store every morning click the Apps tab
and look at the top 150 paid and free
apps on the iTunes Store to get a sense
of when things are bottling up both Yik
yak but snapchat a lot of these things I
kind of watched grow organically through
that channel before the tech memes of me
codes even wrote about them and so it's
about putting in the work those are your
two tips of the day everybody thank you
so much for watching episode 29 of the
askgaryvee show here in San Francisco
again let me know what you think of the
3 question format versus the 5 you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
o Pratt wait subscribe
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social so
subscribe